[Music]
yeah he's great interesting guys and
Prince but my daughter's been
inconsistent today she was born making
Markel's father Thomas Marco breaks his
silence in his first TV interview after
he missed the Royal Wedding due to heart
surgery he opened up on Mondays good
morning Britain with Piers Morgan and
Susanna Reid daddy has a new boyfriend
and and I said that's really nice and
then the next call was like he's British
and I said well that's really nice and
then eventually the time around was like
he's a prince Tom is sharing his side of
the story on how Prince Harry and
Megan's courtship turned into a happily
ever after before a news broke of their
engagement Harry stayed true to
tradition asking for Megan's hand in
marriage
they called me together and Harry asked
for her hand over the phone and I said
you're a gentleman promise me you will
never raise your hands against my
daughter and of course I give you my
permission Thomas also apologized for
staging paparazzi photos calling it a
serious mistake I will absolutely want
to do walk my daughter down the aisle
and also express his feelings about
Megan being walked down the aisle by
Prince Charles instead of him how can I
ask her a better replacement for Charles
I was thrilled to cheers that he was
doing that for him I just wish had been
my hands holding my daughter not his but
it was wonderfully doing that one step
at a time and we'll start of found me
well Thomas has the same hope for the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex she's one of
children for a long time yes and and she
said when when she when she met Harry
and she spoke about how much she loves
him there's got to be a child and making
somewhere soon
you
[Music]